et on en vient la situation sanitaire où
le nombre de cas positifs au coc u19 aux
états unis est en nette augmentation
selon les dernières données des
autorités sanitaires sont treize mille
cas un nouveau ont été enregistrés en
moyenne ces derniers jours face à cette
vague épidémique de plus en plus d'état
et d'entreprises ont décidé d'imposer la
vaccination aux salariés et pour en
parler on va tout de suite rejoindre
notre correspondant à washington thomas
bonnin
thomas bonsoir alors comment sont perçus
ces nouvelles mesures aux états unis
et bien le fait que la vaccination
obligatoire gagne du terrain aux
etats-unis c'est un fait qui a été salué
ce jeudi par les autorités sanitaires
américaines qui ont tenu un point presse
elle se félicite que de plus en plus
d'employés fédéraux des universités
d'entreprise privée ait décidé d'imposer
la vaccination à leurs salariés ou à
leurs étudiants et il ya même des états
qui souhaitent montrer l'exemple en
allant encore un peu plus loin c'est le
cas par exemple de l'état de californie
où le gouverneur a annoncé de nouvelles
mesures je propose d'écouter
l'état de californie toujours dans
l'idée de montrer l'exemple a également
affirmé que nous devions faire plus et
faire mieux en devenant le premier état
du pays a exigé un passeport vaccinale
ou au moins d'exiger un test pcr
nous adaptons donc notre stratégie
aujourd'hui pour l'aligner sur celle de
l'état et ainsi devenir le premier état
du pays a exigé que tout notre personnel
pas seulement les enseignants le
personnel a crédité les paras éducateurs
le personnel d'entretien et chauffeurs
de bus les gens qui sont essentielles
pour soutenir l'ensemble de l'écosystème
scolaire se mettent également à une
vérification de la vaccination et où se
soumettent à des tests hebdomadaires
alors il faut noter que le plus grand
syndicat de professeurs aux états unis a
salué cette mesure et s'est prononcé
donc en faveur de la vaccination
obligatoire pour les professeurs sur
l'ensemble du territoire américain pour
moment il n'y a pas de mesures au niveau
fédéral de la part du gouvernement
américain la liberté est donnée aux
différentes localités d'ailleurs les
autorités sanitaires lors de ce point
presse ce jeudi ont expliqué qu'il n'y
aurait pas non plus de bases de données
au niveau fédéral des preuves de
vaccination pas de qr codes à la
française donc pour le moment ici et
libertés est donc donné aux états
notamment de décider d'apposer ou non de
nouvelles mesures et on assiste en
réalité à une bataille entre les états
démocrates et les états républicains il
ya notamment deux états républicains qui
sont dans le viseur des autorités
sanitaires et plus généralement du
gouvernement américain il s'agit de du
texas et de la floride puisque les
autorités sanitaires américaines lors de
ce point presse ont affirmé que 40 % des
hospitalisations dans le pays en ce
moment sont concentrées justement dans
ces deux états deux états ou les deux
gouverneurs républicains sont opposés
aux mesures de restriction par exemple
dans le texas le gouverneur a annoncé
qu'il allait lancer des poursuites
contre tous ceux qui décideraient
d'imposer le port du masque à
l'intérieur de l'état et puis en floride
le gouverneur a lui annoncé qu'il
pourrait y avoir des retenues sur
salaire pour les dirigeants des
établissements scolaires qui là encore
souhaiterait imposer le port du masque
le gouverneur de floride run de santis
préfère que ce soit aux parents de
décider s'ils veulent ou non faire
porter le masque à leurs enfants la
ciste donc à un bras de fer entre ses
élus républicains et le président joe
biden on a même assisté à une passe
d'armes entre le gouverneur de floride
run de santis et joe biden ces derniers
jours par médias interposés une fracture
politique autour du commis 19 qui n'est
finalement pas nouvelle parce qu'il faut
se rappeler que l'an passé déjà lorsque
donald trump était président des états
unis il y avait eu quelques débats faut
se souvenir notamment que des démocrates
dont joe biden et kamala harris lors de
la dernière campagne présidentielle
s'était montré plutôt sceptiques quant à
la capacité de donald trump de pros de
proposer un vaccin à la population
américaine
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnaire en direct
depuis washington